this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
well we couldn't have asked for a better
way to start our Sunday then the
brand-new Oh balls of fluff for the in
Karuma pride these are twelve two of
them you can just see one at the moment
the second one is with mom and is
lounging about and will hopefully get a
view of that little when just now my
name is Kristen on camera I've got
myself this afternoon hopefully you're
going to love the fact that we are going
to spend time with the in kuma Cubs for
the very very first time isn't it the
sweetest visible face look at that big
yawn and they are super chilled they
don't worry about us at all when we
drove in in fact the one didn't even
wake up it was so fast asleep with mom
now remember that we are coming to you
live from South Africa and Kenya in the
Masai Mara and so we want you to ask
lots and lots of questions and I'm sure
you'll have lots of comments about the
fact that we've managed to find the
little Cubs and so because of that we
want you to use hashtag Safari live on
Twitter
or at if see on the YouTube chat and
talk to us about it now I'm hoping this
little one will go to where mommy's
mommy is hidden behind this quarry you
can just see her hid and the other
little one is tucked up around her back
legs I think it's having a little drink
of milk it looks like a tiny little cub
that's with her there so I think maybe
just maybe it might even be a boy and a
girl already cuz the one that we were
seeing out in the open is much much more
or looks a lot bigger than the other one
already and is far braver at this stage
this Hawthorn is super curious it's been
watching us the whole time we've been
here look if this keeps kind of looking
at us as if to say can I come and play
it is the cutest little thing ever so a
bit of perseverance has paid off Joel
you say hey new Cubs yes it's the best
thing ever is to have little fat lion
cubs they are the cutest things when you
get new Cubs now these Cubs you can see
you still got spotty little heads and aw
Stinney tiny tiny still so they're not
brand new I mean they're not a few days
old but I would put them at around six
weeks
there'd be too much more than that and
so very very sensitive area this and
what that means is that we're going to
obviously have to call them in but the
sighting will probably be off-limits for
the rest of today after we've spent some
time here and then they'll have to kind
of put in place what they're gonna do it
normally be a one vehicle sighting if
moments presents miss anonymous you say
you feel like a godparents indeed it
does feel like being a little godparent
oh look at that little fat tummy hello
little cute one where you off to
I'm so fluffy little legs as well that's
gonna go to where mommy is I'm just
gonna roll for you myself cuz the other
ones just popped its head up as well and
it's actually quite a nice view and you
can see that they are fairly fairly
relaxed unless mom moves if mom moves
then you find that it's a bit more
tricky now they're going there it's just
under mum hello
no mum are you going to lie to us
somewhere nicely where we can see both
the little ones and you that would be
very pleasant I'm hoping she's gonna
walk a little bit to the left where she
was lying this morning because it's much
easier but you can see that one day it
just seems a little bit smaller than the
other one they are super cute look at
that little wobble typical little Cubs
that's for sure and she's gonna lie
actually fear the back now um I don't
know how we going to see them myself
it's going to be very tricky it's a
quarry thicket that we're in I'm gonna
try and go forward a little bit for
Marcel obviously gotta be a bit
sensitive about how you move when you
with Cubs you don't want to move too
fast or too far how can you see them
through there so Marcel saying you can
see them nicely through there which is
good here they are bundling off towards
mom and so while we try and figure out a
slightly better view I'm gonna send you
across I think to Jamie and could have
been James with is Jamie James is gonna
make it difficult for the afternoon and
see what they say for today
Hassan oh my boy I fear for the very
first time you might just have been
overshadowed temporarily no you will of
course always be
almost everyone's favorite a very good
afternoon to all I'm so excited for
Tristan my name is Jamie and a behind
the camera is a Craig and of course
everybody thrilled to see the new data
link Akuma Cubs Tristan myself and Craig
worked quite hard for them this morning
so that's very very exciting news
yay I think that Craig is kind of
devastated that he is not with Tristan
now he was with Tristan this morning as
we did a very concerted search around
that area we have Herbie to thank for
hasanah
sitting at muffled hugged am he is
currently slotted into an erosion gully
in the ground that looks very
uncomfortable but like all cats he has
managed to make it look comfortable
somehow good his poor tucked away in
there of course what he's waiting for
he's decided that boy Taylor Dam is no
longer the place to be for now what he's
waiting for is for something to come
down and have a drink at which point he
can use his ambush skills they're still
a little bit of water left in Buffalo
Dam not much it's basically just a dried
up mud puddle but it'll be enough to
attract animals forget him he's
ridiculous he has you know children
puppies and cats can make any sleeping
position look comfortable somehow he'd
slotted into the dried-out mud I just
need to chat on the game drive radio
briefly in a moment so at least just
listen to it and it sounds like there's
quite a few people interested in him
look at that neat little row of spots
those tiny tiny spots he's got just
above his left eye his left eye in his
ear I never noticed those before
oh it's a really thoroughly exciting way
to start our afternoon we're going to
sit here presumably for the rest of the
afternoon it send you across to Lauren's
see what her plans are good afternoon
good afternoon welcome to your sunset
Safari now of course has already been a
very eventful little Cubs and spots
could it be any better probably not now
my name is Lauren and on camera today I
have Sam and we are actually on our way
to Shitsville the others may have
mentioned but it's actually a very hot
afternoon very similar to yesterday cold
mornings cold evenings but really hot
afternoon so cheetah is the biggest
waterhole that we can traverse so we
thought let's unhide on them there and
see exactly who's trying to cool down
and who's trying to have a drink
so we're almost heading in there and
we're just gonna explore the area to see
exactly who is around of course there
will be the usual suspects of the
proposed and the Crocs but check bar can
be a very very surprising place now just
a quick update from my side I drove past
the area that we had the sticks this
morning which is just the western side
of twin dams and they were no longer
there of course they didn't have much
shade this morning and it's it's really
hot so I mean it was inevitable that
they were actually gonna move to an area
that was just a bit more shady so
they're probably still around but we
just don't know where so they're no
longer in the place that they were this
morning which is why we are heading on
in
on a day like today many animals will
come down to drink because it's a little
bit unexpected heat of course it should
be a little bit cooler than this I
believe for winter so many many animals
should be here to drink well I hope so
at least
so we shall see when we get there but
I'm very jealous of Tristan right now
how gorgeous we finally finally finally
get to see the Inca who my Cubs so
talking of those cubbies let's go back
across and see how they're doing
well we've tried to reposition slightly
we can get a bit of view of her and then
but unfortunately it's a very tricky
area and I don't want to drive too close
to her anyway we'll bash down trees
so we've taken as much of an open
clearing as we can and just trying to
watch the little Cubs from quite far so
you can see there in the background
playing with mom's tail at the moment
which is always the best game is playing
with mom's tail it's they often do it
and the black tuft is the perfect thing
to bite and pull and kind of have you
know the best time as a little cub so
we'll just see how it goes but very very
exciting to have these two little balls
of fluff hopefully they come round to
where moms hit is because then we gonna
see them a lot better than where they
are at the moment a little bit hidden at
the moment and that's because of all the
kind of bush and like I said I don't
really want to offer too much yeah hit
trees or anything like that the less
disturbance we make around here the
longer they are going to stick around
right now because it's always a joyous
occasion to have little Cubs we're going
to try and show a lot more people this
so I'm just going to stop speaking for a
little bit while we set that up
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to South Africa in a very very
special moment we are seeing two
brand-new little lion cubs for the very
first time this afternoon
they are cute little balls of fluff and
seemed to be full of beans now you can
see this mom lying over there and the
two little ones are kind of playing
around hopefully we'll get a slightly
better view but as is life with sort of
lion dances that is generally in the
thicker denser areas and so we don't
want to crash around and disturb the den
at all they want to try and be as
respectful as possible so for now it's
going to be fairly sort of long distance
views of them in the kitchen you can see
that one is having the best time with
mom's tail now before we kind of get
into all of this I need to just tell you
who I am so that I'm not a disembodied
voice in the background my name is
Christina on camera I've got Marcel this
afternoon and it is a very warm welcome
to you and remember that we are coming
to you live which means that you can ask
any questions or post any comments that
you have in the comment section below
and we'll try and answer as many as
possible now the little Cubs that you
seeing there we reckon are around about
six weeks old somewhere around there
they're still very small very spotty but
their eyes are open and they can see
that they're moving on isn't that cute
look at that now she's getting groomed
that's very special there are the cutest
cutest little things in the whole wide
world very very fortunate to be able to
spend time with lion cubs like listen to
have a lioness that's being so
accommodating and letting us into life
now and just listen a while can actually
hear them squeaking
stop squeaking now James you want to
know how many Cubs were born
well James we don't know how many were
born but there's only two Cubs here that
we can see so we've got um two little
ones I haven't even been able to see
what six they are literally we just
found them five minutes ago and so you
know it hasn't been a long period to be
able to kind of work out exactly what's
going on but to is what we know of and
they have been seen by a neighboring
part of the reserve a few days ago and
they also any sort too so I suspect that
it's only two but you can see what she's
doing at the moment you see how she's
grooming this little one they'll often
groom quite heavily towards the back end
of the little cub and the reason why
they do that is that they'll actually
stimulate that little cub to go to the
toilets the grooming of the area under
the tail whether it's a boy or a girl
will actually kind of get them to start
trying to actually go to the toilet and
try and actually urinate so Jalal I have
absolutely no idea very difficult to six
lion cubs at this age and they're very
very small and so to seeing the
difference between boys and girls is
quite hard especially if the tails are
not up and so what are we gonna try and
do is hopefully get a bit of a better
view of them at some point and then we
would be able to tell if it's a boy or a
girl but like I said we don't want to
crash in there and drive too close where
we can drive on top of her because
ultimately then she's gonna move the
Dane very quickly so it's better just to
stay back for now and wait
so Denise you're asking if there's any
idea of how old my mom is Shruti nice
novel to remember it's been a while
since I've thought about mom and how old
she is she is one of the older females
within the pride and so if you give me
two seconds I should be able to find her
age fairly quickly she is now about
eight years but I might be wrong she's
somewhere there I'll just double check
I've got a cheat sheets somewhere on
them I'll get back to you now now I have
to try and find it
and kind of get back to she is one of
the older females within the pride she
comes from a pride of 10 which consists
of four adult females and then the rest
of sub-adults to our several males you
know for some adult females that are
almost of breeding age they were all
around about three years old and so
they're gonna be coming into breeding
fairly soon but they haven't as yet head
covers can you hear them little squeaks
this one coming out
how cute is that
so Kathy they belong to a pride called
the in Kakuma pride which is the
dominant pride here in the sabe small
the northern part of the Saba piece and
they're an incredible pride in the last
time we saw little Cubs from the
uncommon pride on Juma was over a year
ago so it's a very long time since we've
seen the Cubs and so it's nice to have
just all one's gracing our presence
again now the exciting thing about the
Akuma pride at the moment is I st. you
that there's these sub adults look at
those little feet isn't that cute it's
playing with mom and trying to kind of
bat mom and you can see their little
paws in the air I know it's a bit
difficult through all the branches but
very very sweet and to see but it's the
exciting thing about the in koma pride
at the moment is that we've had a new
coalition of males come in over the last
few months and I say a few months it's
almost a year now but they are mating
with pretty much all the females and all
the females almost looking like some of
them are pregnant some of may be given
birth and so we should get an explosion
of little ones feeling soon which will
make the pike row quite nicely it's
exciting when you've got this many kind
of females that could come into East
hrus fairly soon and then you'll get all
the cubs kind of growing up together and
the last time the improvers had a really
big batch of cubs was three different
female four different females that gave
birth at the same time and they all kind
of then were able to raise the mineral
mr. Christian environment and so
hopefully that's gonna be the case
because much easier to raise them if
there's a lot of Cubs than there is I
mean it's just the two lockers
especially in an area like this which is
a predator rich environment and with
lots of other
threats to them a little bit forward for
you because there's a little bit of a
branch there that's Marcel's got to give
marsala slightly better view I don't
want to go too far cause I've got a tree
in front of me that's much better isn't
it
there we go so that's a much nicer view
of the little ones and you can see look
at that one on its back
isn't that cute it has got to be the
cutest thing to watch the lion cubs
now Susan when will they be introduced
to the pride so it's obviously it's
dependent but generally we start to see
that around sort of 10 to 12 weeks is
when we start to see them kind of
joining the prides more often that's
when there's a kill and they'll be
brought to the pride eat with them and
then kind of be hidden again and when
they're actually walking with the pride
that's generally around sort of four
five six months depending on the line is
that they're integrated into the pride
and they'll walk with them and then only
kind of stay off when they're lionesses
hunt come back then they carry on but
when they still little like this now
they are what's in Dean what's called
insights and so where we are at the
moment is the perfect perfect place if
Marcel comes out you'll see what I'm
talking about about how thick it is and
how lucky we are to be able to spotted
her here the ability to track lines on
foot and to try and kind of work out
where they've gone is how we and find
them and so we're these Cubs are being
hidden is to the right of where she is
at the moment that left side there is a
little bit more open but to the right
here you can see it becomes a wall of
vegetation and there is a termite mound
that's got a little holes in it with a
tree that grows out and that's where
they're being stored it's not a place
they haven't used before um lines or the
in comer pride um have used this den
site performance why were you in we
heard that they had come this way that
we checked cared and should try and find
them
so Maria liens change their Danes quite
quickly they they don't often sit for
long periods in the same game and what
you'll find with these guys is that they
will typically try and move the din
every you know week or two weeks
sometimes a little bit longer sometimes
a little bit less and the previous Dame
to this as far as we can establish was
only used for about a week and she's now
moved him across so there was seen for
the first time about a week ago and then
she's moved him across not to the stain
site here where they're kind of moving
around and onto our area where we can
traverse and then so that's why we
seeing them for the first time this
afternoon but normal about a week two
weeks depends obviously or sir how many
Cubs if there's any threats that are
around so if hyenas find this den if
lipid walks past if lions walk past
that's going to dictate how long she
sticks at is that a little boy or a
little girl lift your tail again
difficult to see it looks like it might
be a little girl I don't see any testes
but at this age the testes are so small
on the cub that it's very very difficult
to know whether or not they are boy or
girl and have to get a really clear view
but you can see mom's tail is the base
game look at that
so special and now she's being bugged by
a branch not only who comes but a branch
too right
well I hope that all of you enjoyed that
very special intimate look into a
lionesses life you've got to be very
lucky to be allowed to be this close to
lines with the inital Cubs and she's
been very accommodating to us and so
we're not gonna overstay our welcome too
much but I hope that you enjoyed it and
remember if you do want to carry on
seeing how these little Cubs grow you
can just google Safari Live and join us
as we continue the journey with them
over the coming weeks months and years
to fight for myself and Marcel's been an
absolute pleasure and we look forward to
seeing you all soon
well how special is the sighting now
what's basically happen is I've called
in in the radio that we found him it's
not fair to hide this from everybody and
so I spoke to Rick's mesenteric so you
know I really this morning I had an idea
that they were here so this morning when
I went back I spoke to Rick speak kindly
and said to him listen can we go this
afternoon check in he said sure and he's
basically entrusted us to see fat how we
do this and so what we going to
basically do with the sighting as the
sighting will be able a one vehicle
sighting going forward and I just
confirmed it with Rick's now and
basically going to have a situation
where we're gonna have it sort of 10 to
15-minute time limit per vehicle with
only one vehicle around at the time and
we're gonna try and make it that it's
only if the female is here but that's
what's gonna happen so we're not gonna
be here for that's much longer and we'll
probably spend a little bit longer just
because luckily we managed to find them
in Rick said we can take our time but I
don't want to deny others the chance to
see tiny little cubs it's a very special
thing to be able to see this rights well
well such a little bit longer in the
meantime though it's send you across to
Lauren who's made a way to jitter them
well we reached shits wah and bizarrely
enough of course why oh you were all
enjoying the little Akuma
Cubby's a lot of hippos were all out the
water they were all standing in the Sun
and I could not see exactly what they
were doing I didn't want to get too
close because hippos can be quite
unnerving and of course if I got too
close they would just go away but indeed
in the end they all just went back into
the water but it was really bizarre just
to see a collection of maybe 10 to 15
hippos just standing I the wards are in
the Sun and this sort of late afternoon
heat of today it was very strange but of
course they have gone back into the
water and I have to say I'm rather
jealous positions here in exam all I do
I would love to be in water maybe not
necessarily Chippewa dam but I would
love to be immersed in water right now
just like these hippos are they were
doing the water due to their skin they
do need moisture they do need to sort of
witness on their skin not just to cool
them time but also for the actual skin
themselves is extremely sensitive and
even though they've sort of got a thick
layer of fat if you like and it would
take a chainsaw it's probably get
through they do require water for their
skin because it's such a fine epidermis
which makes it really extremely
sensitive to dehydration and I believe
is up to seven times more sensitive than
other mammals and many of you are
wondering if it's because the water is
too cold I really do not believe that we
came down the other morning on the
Sunrise Safari and even before the Sun
was really properly up the hippos were
in the water and of course that's when
the water will be the coldest so on a
day like today the water would be ideal
for them and very soothing and
all that noise never fails to entertain
me but no I really don't believe that
would have been the reason that they
would have been over the water it's not
as if they were feeding or
can't see it though
and slowly but surely behind not the
best angle for said we do have a meal
water buck making his way to the water I
think it's gonna take some time for him
though because of course excuse our
aerial I really it's a terrible angle
hey Makoto of course site managed it the
water bugs do get nervous because they
know they know what lies in store for
them on the banks of check bottom and we
did actually witness a meal Wasser buck
right here the other day Vito walks past
the very large croc with about a metre
and a half to spare of course nothing
happened sir the croc wasn't fast enough
and it was just a bit too far away but
it's not a well it's not an easy task
getting down to the dam the nor what
potential threats lie in store for them
now hence the name you will always find
water Buck's near water they're heavily
dependent on water box a water and the a
meal like this one here say it's up its
territory around a water point so this
is probably this meals territory Linda
seemed wow those horns I know aren't
they just glorious he will come down if
we have Ruby here patiently but but it's
definitely gonna take some time
the horns are absolutely fantastic very
different from other antelope species
now I do feel it's worth weeding out a
little while here to see if anything
else does come them to drink herd of
Impala were here earlier it is the
perfect D for animals to come down
I was hoping me but maybe see an
elephant or two it's been a while since
I've seen an elephant in chat with them
and of course we have our regulars look
at the way is positioned is that my eyes
or is it got its legs been I think it's
got this little leg he's been yeah of
course we do know there is a couple a
male and female saddlebow stork so this
is most likely one of them so as our
water buck makes its way to the edge of
the water very slowly and cautiously
we're gonna send you guys back over to
Tristan and the Cubbies
as you can see some are going for water
others are going for milk and the tea
little Cubs are still suckling lien mom
is getting a chance to have a bit of a
rest or she has to probably go out and
try and see if she can find food so the
two little ones just kind of tucked up
there and I'm sure it's they suckling
now because it's that time of the day
with Sun slowly starting to come down
and they know they're gonna get hidden
soon and they're gonna be pushed into
the den she's gonna then go marching off
which is going to be good no like I said
to you earlier I was explaining a little
bit about den sites and how they work at
this age they're very very sensitive and
so the movements of cars and the
constant driving around and things like
that is is can very much to stove a
lioness at insight and so you need to be
very respectful and there needs to be
certain rules that are applied and so
how it will work and it will affect
obviously how we view these Cubs over
the course of the next few weeks is that
essentially these den sites particulars
one is in a very difficult to reach area
in some respects it's very thick it's
very dense there's a lot of sensitive
trees Archer and so we need to be quite
careful about how we move it so I was
just speaking to Rex now quickly I mean
he was saying to me what he had liked is
rather because Rex obviously he looks
after the juma property in terms of
off-roading in those kind of things and
you're saying you'd like it to be just a
one vehicle sighting and that checks the
den every day and there's no rotation of
vehicles after that just for the next
few days until such time as we kind of
establish what's going on exactly how
things are working um but we're going to
rotate art with one person today just to
allow them to see and basically what
happens is the den is only allowed to be
used or visited during daylight hours so
never at night just because hyenas often
will move into this area
and that's obviously it's incredibly
dangerous for little lion cubs and so
the point is to try and be here in the
times that are least impactful on the
slyness she's obviously very relaxed
she's not growling you know she's not
hissing at us which is perfect and the
Cubs are very relaxed too and we don't
want to chase them or make them move
around because ultimately all that's
going to do is just disturb this entire
area and she's just gonna move the Cubs
again and she might move them off our
property and we're right in the corner
of our property so if we play our cards
right hopefully she'll stick around here
for a few a few days and few weeks and
then maybe move them deeper into Juma so
we'll just have to kind of see how it
goes but like I say that your respect is
the sort of name of the game and it's
why we're not gonna be staying for much
longer that's all you know moving arts
after we done with this segment because
like I said we did one other person see
and then it's gonna be closed off for
the evening for her to have her peace
and quiet with her little ones and it's
very very special there that we have
little in common times I always love the
fact that we do once they get a little
bit older ones they start reaching sort
of three months then you can start
rotating vehicles through your feelings
quickly and it's not a huge train smash
as to how many vehicles comes through
and that's they're a lot more mobile at
that point but initially when they
smaller cousin it particularly because
she moved in this morning to this date
you don't want to over pressure place
that she's just moved him to because of
our she's just gonna move to begin
somewhere else look at who's in that
suite
marriage knows I've done my girl
very very good
a lot of you are asking where the den is
in terms of in relation to her or in
terms of where on juma or in terms of
means obviously different things but
well basically we're in the the
northwest corner of Juma
when actually not far from the the Gary
gates area so kind of northwest of the
camp not far from Sidney's damn Gary
gates some emini that kind of corner
there that we're in so it's an area that
is tricky to negotiate and finding her
this morning was no mean feat I had a
hunch that she might be coming to this
exact spots and so it's why we checked
yeah but Craig spotted her from a mile
away and as you can see less than ideal
terrain so not very very lucky to have
been able to see yeah that is cute
though they are very sweet little things
that's for sure
very cute now I'm not sure if anyone
gots a screenshot of that one with its
little tail up to see if it's a boy or a
girl but I didn't get to see nicely
really normally at about three months is
when the Cubs are starting to eat meat
and so you know probably in about six
weeks time I would imagine I say six
weeks
it's a rough guess just based on size
and spots and the mobility and those
kind of things they might be a little
bit old it could be six to eight weeks
that would be my guess I should have you
know we've had a look between all of us
at pictures that were posted by some OB
this morning and we all agreed around
that age and seeing them in person I
suspect that that's about how old they
are and they grow quite quickly and so
for me the rough sort of age that I
would put them at their at their cutest
at this phase vote for me I always think
that fluffy little Cubs like this are
the cutest things in the whole world and
what's really nice to see is that they
are completely relaxed when I drove in
here for me first Katja mom was asleep
and we actually drove fairly close
because I didn't expect that little Cubs
to be lying so far from mom and they
just looked at me as though there was
nothing in the world that was wrong at
all and so that's a really good sign
that they are not too stressed about
things and that's good going forward so
it's all going to be good then I think
we're gonna have lots of memorable
sightings of these just ones while I
hope so I mean I think I'm a private to
continues to grow good we're gonna leave
these two in the meantime though we're
gonna send you to another of the film
favorites here on Juma and that is Jamie
with the little chief
and he was also very very cute when he
was a little cub but I do agree with
Tristan those tiny baby lion cubs at
that age especially that little sound
that they make thing low sound is just
it tugs at one's heartstrings it brings
back memories of a time when the kuma
was dating remember just to the eastern
side of Buffalo dam which is where we
are now and the three females gave birth
almost at exactly the same time Ridge
knows the purple eyed lioness and then
the oldest lioness who died recently
well their birth 1-year birth on
Torchwood one gave birth here and one
gave birth the oldest lioness gave birth
around Galago pan just to the north of
that the only one that we really had the
only den site we really had access to
was the one that was here just to the
north of the strain in line remember
many times creeping in there slowly just
to have a look with the car see the
little movement of the little ones I'm
excited because I think that it's not
just going to be the ridge noise female
we're going to see lots more little
babies shortly Kasana
has shifted out if he's incredibly
uncomfortable looking position now his
father or at least his likely father as
you know I recently collected a nice
fresh pile of scat to test that theory
but in Ghana is just to the north of us
in bottles hook very very close to the
I'm just gonna turn this down slightly
Tristan's just giving instructions as to
where to drive if they any vehicles that
do want to see the Cubs and he's very
very close to where husana is now and I
suspect before the night is over
Dingaan is going to come back down
towards a buffalo
I think already he's moved from where he
was this morning I know Rex ins busy
searching for him so we might just have
a little bit of father-son interaction
ah apparently many of you asking if
husana has had any further interaction
with pretty the hyena I don't think so
I mean unless she has bought some sort
of court case against him I think that
he is probably in the clear there so no
I don't think that they've had in the
interaction who knows we don't know what
goes on in the middle of the night out
here so perhaps he has and I'd have
absolutely no doubt that that is the
knot that is not the last interaction
that he's going to have with a hyena for
those of you that missed it although I
sincerely doubt there are too many
people in the dark anymore
he tackled pretty as she very smugly
came trotting through the open area
outside of our camp carrying a very
large piece of skin with a little bit of
meat still attached to it and this hyena
came trotting along and he basically
used the pure element of surprise to
shoot out grabbed the kill from her and
climb a tree before she'd even had a
chance to gather her wits no I don't
think he's had any further interaction
at least not that we know of but I'm
sure that she she's fine he's fine and
he's just very lucky that animals
actually can't bring court cases
otherwise she could sue him for assault
and theft
mind you I'm pretty sure he would have a
very solid counterclaim
I think I've got your name right but I
might be completely off creepy or II
would like to know whether or not
leopards will ever hunt smaller big cats
yes they absolutely do
hi guys they do hunt smaller big cats 3
P 3 P not creepy I'm sorry
I agree I'll get there eventually the
what does I do about oh yes they do hunt
smaller cats they've been known to catch
wild cats or Santa himself is called a
wild cat before
oh it's my little friend the little boy
who said hello to all the Lions last
night that was so cute hello man oh so
sweet I think he just said Hello Kitty
again oh hello Tony
what hello Tony again hey he's the only
boy in the world that gets away with
calling me Tony what was I talking about
Oh I've also seen pictures of leopards
in trees with dead Cheetos so yes they
do they'll they will kill lion cubs if
they happen to find lion cubs unattended
you'll find that with all of the
predators there's an element of
competition and as a result what they'll
do is they will if they can they will
remove any of the young if possible
Kenya's young cheetah cubs actually
survived a leopard attack not well I say
not too long ago it must have been a
year ago now while we were filming the
gauntlet series
all right well since Hassan has been
thoroughly thrilling at the moment we're
going to let him snooze away and
interrupt it and we'll send you a cross
to Lauren in the meantime wow we have
found a very large crop sunbathing shall
we say and that is literally what it is
doing basking on the banks in the Sun
trying to heat up of course because he
or she is a reptile and talking of
gender male and female crocodiles
actually have an internal sex organs so
it makes it very very difficult to
actually from where we are looking tell
them apart from the sort of while
external morphological features alone
now unless you're conducting a really
close inspection is almost impossible to
tell because crocodiles actually have
events this is also known as a cockle
slit and this is where these sex organs
are sort of kicked inside which you
would not get to see unless you get very
very close to them though they do see
that sort of meals have a thicker tail
well a tail beef they're stronger bill
and they do grow larger but unless
you're actually looking at a comparison
of the two it's very difficult to tell
just from what we're looking at right
now so it's only really when males are
ready to meet that their actual penis
expands out of the vein and it is
inserted into the female's fan so it's
only really when they're meeting that
you sort of can get a better indication
of his meal and whose female and his
testes actually do remain inside the
body at one time so unless you've got a
male and female croc of the same age
lying on the bank like this it's really
difficult to tell
so fire lovers asking about the water
sources so PSAPs giving you a beautiful
view of Chippewa time and you can see
right here where we're looking right now
used to be filled with water and that
sort of tree that's at a very odd angle
now right in the middle and that one yep
same and that one it was used to be
Islands if you like and they were just a
tiny little mound of land sticking out
of the water and as you can see it's all
dry lands now so Chatsworth um
definitely has the most water out of all
the times that we Traverse it's the
largest and it's still got a lot of
water in there it's relatively deep and
it still definitely got enough water to
last us a while however the other dams
are not looking so great we did drive
past twin dams on the way here and it's
always safe to see that it's completely
dry treehouse is okay boo fools who I'm
sure I think that's where Hosanna is so
maybe Jamie could possibly give you a
view if that's where he is so yes the
water is getting more and more scarce as
we sort of progress into Windsor and
forget the fishy go fly and he's coming
right towards us oh he's gonna land
right there
nice one say look at that
just landed right ahead of the car
doesn't look necessarily very
comfortable all I have to say it doesn't
have to come free there to see I love
these birds and of course a very iconic
if you come down to Chitra and you don't
hear the fish ego called and something's
wrong I was kind of hoping it would
maybe call when we could hear it
now I'm I personally find identifying
birds of prey and rats are quite
difficult you really have to focus on
the features in order to work out
exactly which bird it is or you could
potentially make a wrong ID yes Janet I
agree gorgeous creature totally agree
with you so you have to be really really
careful and just make sure you go
through the key identification features
before you sort of make a noise came
from the Egyptian geese but I can't see
them so yes when it comes to the fish
eco I mean you can't miss it
you really can't miss this bird it's
very iconic it's very distinctive of
course with the clashing of the white
head and the brown body if you like and
like any of the birds of prey the
females are bigger than the males
so when you see a monogamous pair
together you shouldn't technically be
able to work out whose meal and whose
email just by looking at the size that
you would only be able to do that when
they're actually together looking at it
like this is very very difficult
oh my goodness you can use my hands show
everyone how [ __ ] well you see how far
away it is from muscles actually hippos
is very very far away so this is gonna
be a bit tricky and I think I would a
stir meat and hide no this is not
wingspan in height I would see the fish
eagle is about this what do you think
Seb a little bit more but in terms of
wingspan it's got a very very very large
wings and I can actually check on my
bird up they do have the bird app and it
gives you the exact wingspan to the
exact measurement so let's see if I can
find this somewhere in here essentially
we up to two point five kilograms and
that's how heavy they are 3.5 kilograms
would be just over 5 pounds I can't see
oh and the females can actually go up to
3 kilograms
there you go which is well over 6.4
pounds I think that could be completely
wrong
I think the wings the height sorry can
go up to 75 centimeters according to
this app which is just under a meter so
about between 2 to 2.5 feet I love
snacks the same wow that is big it is is
a big ego of course very difficult to
judge from here but it is he very very
powerful and big ego that huge beak
there is extremely powerful as well as
the talons they use both when their
sorts of hunting so they are big very
very large and of course they do
predominantly fish but I didn't need to
tell you that and apparently they're
actually capable of lifting pre about 2
kilograms out of the water so they've
got the strength
I think the question from crystal is how
does it see fish yet from where it is
basically um they have very very keen
eyesight for sure so like many of the
birds that eat fish including your
seabirds and different climates they're
actually able to see the fish underneath
the water from being high up and having
quite a sort of vantage point up there
they're able to see the reflection and
the glimmer of the fish underneath the
water and and it takes a lot of
dedication Swift movement and agility to
actually go down in there and use their
talons to be able to quickly grab the
fish and get it out of the water as soon
as possible and the fact that they're
able to grab fish that are really really
really heavy almost pushing on their
body way shows you the sort of size of
the ego and the strength that has in
those wings and of course it wants to
get the fish out of the water as soon as
possible because well as you know fish
don't survive out of the water
so it's much more of an advantage for it
to get it and sometimes fish Eagles are
even known to drop the fish on land
until it dies
we have a question is this the only
species of fish eagle in South Africa
and I believe so it's called the film
name is actually the african fish eagle
so we have many different Raptors out
here but I believe this is the only
species of fish ego that we have in this
area and it is found in throughout the
continent as well as not just sort of
localized to where we are right now and
it's just a glorious glorious bird
now I can start to feel the temperature
is getting marginally cooler not just
marginally it's getting a little bit
sort of easier so as that Sun Goes Down
I think it's gonna be a really good idea
to actually keep an eye on the time to
see who comes time for a drink
I love prioritised asana there so as we
just hang around to time a little bit
longer we're gonna send you across to
Hasan on husana sitting next to the dry
deaf area of waffle sock damn this is
the drainage line that feeds one of the
drainage lines that feeds into before
sub dam itself and I'm actually amazed
I've come down into the drainage line
and I found that I actually have signal
here which I did not expect at all so at
least we've managed to get a view that's
not the back of his head and our little
prince is starting to stir you can see
his heads up listening Oh big neck
stretch starting to look quite
distinguished actually nice big UUM I
think there's a good chance he's gonna
get up but no oh I was gonna say might
not necessarily go for a drink
big cat stretch listen here buddy
don't you be going to Buffalo itself now
no that's where your dad is but you can
just stay here and make yourself
comfortable and please please let's not
do that
head trip again between Buffalo East and
hippo pools Road it's where his father
took me before the last TV show
I know Lindsey I was just saying this to
Craig Lindsey says that the world is
he's coming back up to where you were I
was just saying to Craig it's nice to be
a leopard of Hassan his age he's pretty
secure in himself now he isn't too
threatened by much and he's fast and he
doesn't have to worry about territorial
patrols he doesn't have to worry about
the
attentions of females guarding the
territory against interloping males he
really has has a pretty nice life I mean
he's still got to find his food and
everything but yes
the whole world is hassan Azam chair and
boy does he take advantage of it okay
we're gonna get going let's go see if we
can catch up with him no no no let's be
it's be a good boy and not go north
let's not really go west either tricky
spot wanna throw us off a cliff face
here
okay
ah marvelous news the Mar has been
battling off some gremlins but up and
running and James would love to be
presented with the opportunity to say
good afternoon hello everybody welcome
to the Marcy morrow as you can see it's
a little intimidated a nearly drove off
the road sorry about that we've had in
this trouble as this afternoon that is
why we're very late so my apologies for
that and what we're doing is driving a
little bit around the north of the maro
triangle and then we're going to go back
to the ER level of pride because they're
still with their Buffalo kill but at the
moment I can't in 15 vehicles of the
sighting and I thought well getting into
a lineup of 15 it was possibly not
something I'd like to do so I haven't
but luckily the juma crew has kept you
all entertained with a lot of action
including two brand new little Cubs
which is very exciting
and I can see an evident I'll get you
into a position when John dree can show
you an effort you see the Evelyn Chandra
the camera will not see the evidence
well it might make two pixels or so oh
you have a rain flap in the way no no I
mean oh yeah there's that an elephant
which is I thought maybe for a second it
was a black rhinoceros is not I hope
you're enjoying those new little cubbies
I'm sure you are
whether you say when was i last out in
the rain the last time i was in the
masai mara actually it rains here quite
a lot it's supposed to be the dry season
now but the dry season has failed to
arrive there it is Rhonda best I can do
and Fred and the current conditions the
best on there well now here the soft
pitter-patter of rain you'll be able to
see the mist in the background
and he pitter-patter of rain sounds like
it might become something [ __ ] more
substantial which will result in my
becoming miserable and boo
looks like ponies own having a Sunday
afternoon mope apparently you can hear
some frogs on the ambient microphone
which makes the ambient microphone more
effective than my ears cuz I sitting on
tiny frogs yes yes they're in the way in
the distance quite a lot of it
crickets sort of insects and I still has
consumption as you can hear he looks a
little bit sad Yin are you looking for a
GPS location a rough estimate which
zebras exactly are you speaking about I
don't know where the zebras are I mean I
imagine their summit they are probably
quite a few herds of that I do you mean
the the vanguard of the migration
they'll be with the wildebeest down near
the sand river where the Sand River
crosses into the sea ringgit I and
possibly just south of that around the
loom I wedge that's probably where the
zebra are in we have seen a few here
sometimes a resident here all year round
and we did see a few of them today we're
going to continue now and in the
meantime let us go back to Tristan who
is unfortunately now driving I suspect
he's had to vacate that sighting on
account of many others wanting to be in
it
I am James I'm driving in the hope of
finding something for our TV show
tonight's because I'm afraid as much as
a little lying cubbies are cute and
they'll be there we're not allowed to
use them because it's going to be dark
and we don't want to sit mom and Cubs
and so we'll leave them there but I did
find tracks unfortunately for what I
think is claw lumber from maybe last
night when she finished her scrub here
going north into puffles Hook but
there's Ben Franklin's and squirrels and
all kinds of things making a lot of
noise outside of Gallagher the whole day
today's what I want to do is just come
and have a little scratch here and just
check maybe she turned and came back
again and she's done exactly like what
she did with Lauren you stay where she
appeared out of thin air yesterday
afternoon so that's hope it could have
also been tundish tracks that I follow
it is very difficult now with the two of
them they both so close in terms of size
of track it's a bit tricky but it seems
Gallagher pan is empty at this stage
you've got to be very lucky to find a
leopard at Gallagher pan in this it's a
sauna because generally what happens
with them is that they are very very
very kind of quickly they drink and then
they go so you got to be there within
that ten minute gap when they are around
or wait I'm going the wrong way sorry
myself I have to drive this way so I can
see the tracks if anything has come to
drink during the day and make sure that
I don't miss any track for a leopard
seems sad that our Buffalo winds here
today they drank at Sydney's this
morning so I don't know if they where
they went this afternoon but they're at
Sydney's down this morning
anything yeah anything cough no no no no
no tracks all right well it was worth
the try from here we'll probably hit
towards bazooka time see if Tinky's come
back in the meantime let's change across
to Jamie who has this what's it get
we're not far from Buffalo cut line
although substantially further to the
east so then way tristan is at the
moment and husana has heard something
moving about in the vegetation I don't
know what it is he's heard I can't see
and I can't hear it could easily be a
herd of Impala
oh so many herds in one sentence coming
across and through to the dam for a
drink if he is kind he will stay on this
massive path that Scuba Steve has
created for us which will allow us to
follow him it moves between hyena Road
and with a sock dam if he is unkind he
is going to take us in to probably one
of the most difficult areas on Juma the
same area where we had that buffalo hunt
many many moons ago Chandra and myself
ended up decidedly stuck trying to know
okay we're gonna sleep he's not going to
sleep he is actually this is this is
Hassan as hunting technique it's the
hunting technique of most leopards walk
to us see something and they lie down
and they just wait and they bide their
time and they rely upon their camouflage
to hide them away until the animals move
closer rather than trying to risk making
a noise creeping up on them
so we sit and so we wait asana if you
reduce some moving could we do it now
while it's the light we have craig and i
have a history of pre TV following
letters through very interesting places
when we arrive back slightly disabled or
we arrive at the start of the TV show is
slightly disheveled often without the
lipid itself
I wonder why he decided to move must
have heard something interesting in
there
you can see he is alert looking around
so these game paths that we're looking
at at the moment they obviously become
more and more prominent the closer to
water you get so but an area like
waffles look down which is one of the
main sources of water will have multiple
paths radiating out in different
directions the hippos use and the
elephants help to maintain as well but
it also means that other animals will
use them so much like a hiking trail or
a road it's easy for them to walk along
here there's less obstacles it's clearer
it's more comfortable for them so they
tend to utilize them that might be what
he's hoping for he's got he's arrived at
a sort of a bend in the game path itself
and maybe he's hoping that something's
going to come wandering around the
corner on their way to the water Hobie
tells me that we just missed a honey
badger when we came in to see her sauna
this afternoon so it's probably our
honey badger friend who has been quite
the regular at waffles work damn itself
Oh welcome to Clem who is a new viewer
and who says oMG those animals are so
lazy what is wrong with them
and the answer to that really is that
there's actually nothing wrong with them
they can be phenomenally active and
physically could outpace you even no and
I don't know you sir forgive me for this
but perhaps you are a mixed martial arts
fighter or maybe you are a participant
in the world's strongest man or woman
competition
perhaps you compete in Ironman but no
matter what and no matter how fat you
are and these animals can outpace you
what they're doing at the moment is
conserving energy because they don't
have regular mealtimes speaking of an
animal that does have a regular meal
time well elephants simply never stop
eating throughout the day which
presumably could be what the elephant is
doing with James at the moment right
here we've got some more elephants here
which is of course a very lovely indeed
it looks like a very very old cow and
her youngster you see our bones are all
sticking out and her face is a little
bit long and hanging I think that do
look slightly older here than they do it
Jumma for example or in the Kruger
because they do tend to be more angular
not quite as round the ones down south
but I think this is an old car you can
see a shoulder sticking out her hips
when we have a look at their hips their
laundry and Gil just a billion I wonder
if she's not pregnant again
up the top there
that's the swelling there if she's
pregnant difficult to tell with its
union uniform color
in here the jackal calling
I'm sure she's raised many youngsters I
sold cow and that's her latest offering
to the world
I'm the little fellow asked for Sunday
walk with his mum
well many of you complimenting the
Ellie's long lashes yes they do have
long lashes don't they from very early
on I'm so much like the giraffe
something to protect the eyes when they
get into the thorny stuff and start
eating that we were asked yesterday if
they get colds and I'm sure there must
be cold today Robin I don't think
there's a mass difference between Cougar
elephants and more elephants I'd say
that mass must be pretty similar I just
think they look at it for shape the ones
in Kruger seemed to be rounder somehow
this angular this pointy bits or fewer
pointy bits and more round bits I mean
if that makes sense
also the tusks in the Kruger tend to be
thicker but not quite as long as they
are here let's have a look at the
backside now John they're higher up yeah
yeah you see that swelling on the right
I would say that she's pregnant again I
used to say that elephants go into
menopause they don't of course we know
that now it's possibly a sort of year or
two before they die they're unable to
breathe they don't have an actual
menopause Safari lover you're wondering
how long they're pregnant for well 22
months we didn't believe it almost two
years elephants will be pregnant
carrying a child I know women really
struggle from you know longer than three
months to carry a child imagine it was
22 months I didn't blame the mind you
and very grateful that I will never have
to carry a child in my reading
and it's interesting because of course
the fetus is quite pretty well developed
in a baby elephant and their long
gestation period I suspect allows for
quite a lot of brain development much
like it does with human beings
I find the gestation of humans and the
development of humans and the slowness
with which human beings develop
absolutely astounding it really is quite
remarkable how helped us the human being
is for many many years after it's born
there is an elephant of course will
suckle certainly for a long time but can
stand immediately Jeff elephants
probably lived to around about 65 years
old remember that they lose their will
they get their final set of teeth
somewhere around or they go forgot I
think it's about 57 57 years or so and
thereafter when that those teeth were
out there then she sort of slowly
starved to death so 65 fully run about a
good age you know much like many of
these statistics that we give you very
few elephants have been followed in the
wild from the day they were born until
the day they died and so a lot of the
information we have comes from guesses
or its inferences now those will not be
from a substantial number of individuals
I don't imagine they're probably around
65 years we think
I wonder if he is cold standing in this
drizzle I certainly would be I'd
complain busily if I was him to my
mother ask her to take me somewhere
sheltered and warm
yes Daniel they do like all mammals now
but is not always successful they will
certainly have premature births and
still bones but remember it's probably
much less dangerous than it is for human
beings in fact we know it is so I'm just
gonna reverse slightly John repossess a
car coming remember human beings of
course are not very well designed for
giving birth because of the angle of our
hips and so human beings have to give
birth through the or the birth canal
goes between the hips wears on most
quadrupedal mammal world all quadrupedal
mammals they that doesn't happen that
they give birth sort of above the hips
and so it's not nearly as dangerous for
a baby or mother in most other mammals
and so the incidence of things likes
stillbirths and part tuition
difficulties and breech births and that
sort of thing will be much less I
imagine oh yeah we're gonna turn around
now and try and head back towards where
the other lot of other priorities see if
we can find them you're gonna go back to
Lauren well I think is on Chitra so we
left chats what we did a little loop
around there just in case anything else
was happening person there not what I
expect these we actually just stopped a
vehicle because the Impala were going
crazy now that somebody like alarm calls
but I think it could just be the male
who's been a bit boisterous and the
rutting season is over but they may
still have sort of excess testosterone
pumping around their body as males do I
don't think it was anything but it was
very very noisy a lot of rapid constant
alarms hmm that's what we're not missing
anything but we are gonna head back onto
German oh just nice and slowly and see
if anything is happening on that side of
the world
okay I really do think it was the meals
just being boisterous no but for a
minute there I thought it was alarm
calls now I've had no updates on the
steaks but I've been on the eastern
channels were not being on Juma radio
channel so I do wonder if there's
anything and we have missed but there's
a high potential that they crossed out
and crossed onto an area that we can
traverse
in Jersey the Sun is setting now
MGM is asking we're with the croc school
when the water dries up in the dam well
same as the hippos they both essentially
rely on the water they do needs to be
close to a water source so if chitwa tom
was to dry up completely man I imagine
they would just relocate another water
source they're both mobile they can
survive with water they're not like a
fish you know they can't walk about it's
very funny when you see crocodile tracks
on the road some don't know why it's
funny but it is to me and I'm just
thinking maybe for a bit yes let's try
it so yes they won't just get out of the
water and go find another water point
they will know where that is and of
course there are areas around here that
do have water all year round so they do
require the water but they can survive
of course without sand because it is
winter a bit Hubbs sort of more of an
effect on the crocodiles MGM than it
works on the hippos because the hippos
skin wouldn't be so badly affected by
the sun's rays because they're not quite
as intense as they are in summer so
we've just taken a little corner here
into the Milwaukee because this is
generally where things like to hang out
when it's hot and of course the Sun is
going down but I think it's definitely
worth a little look to see what we can
see inside here
this would have been an actual ideal
hidey hole for the sticks as well
because they were just over they are
twin dams kind of just there so they
could have easily have just came in here
and got sheets in the Malati
so as we bumble onwards through this dry
riverbed we're gonna send you guys
across the Tristan for an update
hopefully Lauren will have some luck
with the sticks as well as maybe with
something else down that side Whitey's
always a good place to check we check
Gallagher for a little bit side I'm sure
there's going to be a little bits at
some point between categories in a pan
maybe it'll be hosanna by the end of the
the evening as he makes his way that way
I'm not sure but now I have a feeling
that there's going to be tündi or
Columba that's also gonna show up
there's some point tonight as well but
anyway what we're doing is we're just
driving before the cut line because ting
gana hasn't been found where he was left
this morning and we know ting he likes
the physic time area and so just kind of
kind of have a little scratch and
failing that we're gonna hit straight
down to the cut line and then on to the
fire break and check if we can maybe
relocate on Sabri who probably has been
moving for a while or any bits you never
know maybe she's get seen and we get
lucky so that's the kind of plan for now
and just take it as it comes anything
that comes our way will be good we've
had a fine afternoon already it's been
very pleasant to spend time with little
lion cubs and while it's not really I
feel in terms of our TV show story it is
pretty pretty cool nonetheless I'm quite
happy with life and we'll scratch
something out for TV show we generally
do so we'll see how that goes and
otherwise Jamie and James will just have
to hold the fort I'm afraid that's kind
of how it goes
Shazaam you must be a fairly new viewer
yes they are primates in this area and
they are baboons
so these baboons and vervet monkeys and
Bush babies that are around the we quite
thankful at the moment that we're not
seeing many baboons because the ribbons
have got to be the hardest animal Archer
to live with the monkeys are had a all
time bad at the moment they have lost it
all fear of anything and are constantly
berating the kitchen staff and kind of
causing havoc by trying to jump in and
grab food and in fact they even grabbing
foods right off tables in front of
people I think yesterday afternoon
Lauren was sitting on her phone and it
was a carrot that was not more than 20
centimetres from her face and the vervet
monkey stole the carrots and ran off and
I can sympathize because it's not very
much food for them at this time of the
year they obviously desperate to try and
find a meal and so that's what they
looking for is any sort of sign food but
yes baboons own vervet monkeys and then
acid push babies so two different
species of them they say I'm great seer
pic tailed all but it says the other
names so they also occur here too am I
forgetting any other monkeys no I don't
think so no that's
sometimes you want to just double-check
yourself because especially when there's
obscure things that could be around but
that's it so for primates
Prattville pangolins seen in the world
not often I'm afraid depends with you I
suppose actually it depends in which
part of of the world you are some areas
pangolins has seen a lot more than
others in this particular area not at
all I mean we've only had one Pangolin
in almost 12 years of wild Earth's
existence so that gives you an idea of
how here they are here in Amara a little
bit more common we've got we only have
had one on camera but Manu has seen two
there and there's various other
sightings of them quite a few in that
area if you go to where Jamie has just
been in swallow that's they seize
pangolins almost every second third day
and in fact even they've got a research
project going away because pangolins
they are much easier to find and they've
tagged all bunch of the Pangolin so they
can actually follow their movements
trying to learn more about the mating
they're popping the dietary habits so
there is a really good place to go look
for pangolins so just depends there is
various areas and it's but it's always
it's always a rare find that's never an
animal that can ever be guaranteed
and unfortunately in the sabi sands it's
once in a very very very big blue moon
that you will find such things no Sonic
result it's Jamie Stewart or Sanne faith
because there's a lipid track yeah
not very fresh I'm afraid I thought for
a second there might have been a sauna
strike but I mean this is rating Ghana
was seen with straight north of us here
is the right that's gonna go to the left
and he was seemingly lying down now
there's a pan not too far from me so I'm
hoping rather than drinking there he's
going to move southwards and come to you
territorial patrol maybe trinket puffles
exam and then carry on and since why I'm
here at the moment he's in case he moves
at this time of the day that ting he
likes to take a little trendle Tinky's
trundle it sounds like a bar name
somewhere in the world and maybe in the
UK anyway hope we kind of figure out if
he's crossed over and just check around
this area that seems you back cross to
James and the Mara and see how he's
getting on and if he's had any luck
we are driving back towards the Lions
now and will hopefully have sight of
them sometime fairly soon I'm not sure
that this weathers gonna close in any
more than it has already so that's quite
nice I'd like to demonstrate one of the
supreme technological advances that this
particular vehicle exhibits it is called
and I'm sure most of you will be so
amazed by this it's called a windscreen
wiper they're not amazing and it is what
it says it wipes the windscreen
it's incredible watch this isn't that
amazing automatically and we just
affixed it to this car we found it in
the dashboard and with a screwdriver and
a pair of pliers we hammered it on and
it's astoundingly actually removes the
water from the windscreen now I know
that this for many of you will be
starting astounding and I feel almost
bad about revealing it because I feel I
could have made quite a lot of money off
this remarkable thing that I have found
in this vehicle I don't know who
invented it
why it took so long to put on the Land
Rover or why it is that it moves with
such ponderous speed but anyway there it
is very exciting indeed
in City the find of my afternoon second
fine disease elephants on the left which
we will stop and look at
as I'm sure most of you are greatly
amazed by the invention of the
windscreen wiper I also think the name
is quite clever because it tells you
exactly what it is it was almost
certainly not named by an ornithologist
writer Andre I will now Park you in a
position to look at these elephants they
rot there's a very small one over there
that's the one I think we should look at
it wasn't the small one there's a
smaller one even still with its mummy
just to the left of that one well that
one wasn't bad
there we are very nice
um painted wolf guess I suppose they do
I mean most elephant staff to death when
they you lose their when they lose their
molars some will die of disease of
course and some will die of being killed
by other elephants or that sort of thing
but otherwise yes most of is that a lion
go back lift back lift yes there's a
lion had no idea what was going on there
let me move forward a bit she's running
now trying to get away from the
elephants I'm sure she's going to look
towards the kills that was most amusing
just saw a flash of this thing lying
under the tree Arthur Prasad this year's
the vehicles cleared off genre it is
closing time in the path but I also
suspected suppose the Lions have
absconded hello my dear
it's lovely to see you if you could lie
close to a row that'd be wonderful thank
you yeah one of the ole ole ole ole ole
o pride lions I'm assuming yes she's
calling
I think we should go around and see if
we're there there's a male coming
towards a big black main male and a
female you see them there laundry well
done it's very nice
that's a magical picture now luckily
they are in an off-roading Zone but I
won't be able to follow them from here
we'll have to go around I'm gonna
suggest while they're standing up that
we do just that that we don't wait here
because unfortunately we are losing
lights and we need to get around there
if we are going to have any chance of
finding them offroad
while we do this we'll send you back to
Lauren who is now with the stocks pride
I believe thank you we'll just go and
what about that lions - lions Henry -
Arthur we located the Strix pride and
honestly they are exactly opposite where
they were earlier they are still on twin
dams right in the middle of the roads I
mean if you were driving down this road
this is nothing short of a epic
roadblock they've slept all day just
like we said this morning they were
obviously very fool it was a very hot
day I think I've mentioned that possibly
about 20 times now I do apologize so of
course it makes sense for the cats to be
flat now I can see seven I think at the
minute but there should be nine so I'm
more than sure another oh no I just see
another one moving in the glass okay I'm
sure there is no neurons yeah
and it is getting to that time of night
Wayne
cats do start to wake up we do know this
no it's much cooler the sun's not quite
so nyet but it's much much much cooler
I'm even considering putting my scarf on
they're all a week they're starting to
groom you're starting to itch a lot of
them still look very very itchy which is
rather sad and yeah I imagine very
shortly these lions are gonna be highly
mobile which will be very interesting
and I hope they don't cross over and say
I'm sorry that we can traverse I hope we
can follow them because this will be the
first time that I think they have been
they would be seen on a SABC so we've
got a bunch of females here but it looks
like mr. Hendrie has a male let's go up
to the mara
we do indeed have a male lines the same
airline we've come around to the side
and we can see the other one in front of
us still on that buffalo carcass and so
we'll stop and have a look at this chap
it's a nice view of him there you might
try and drive off road here
don't Road you want to try you do all
right
well be it on your head when we get
stuck we shouldn't get stuck yet
under said he wanted to be much closer
and round the other side so I said
that's what I do for him ultimately
these kiddies are going to get to sleep
now everyone these are the kids who are
males in consult with the hola Lola Lola
Lola pride
they might start mating I think we might
have a mating pair here everybody is
this is the chap who's lost the end of
his tail I forget what his name is I
think it's haft he'll something equally
imaginative there's a proper lie on this
I feel like this lion would eat one of
the Avoca males for breakfast
he's obviously much older he goes
jogging after her he's decided the smell
of her urine indicates that she is
perhaps receptive to mating he has not
picked up on the fact that she's leaving
because she is not receptive to mating
and elephants in the background a lot of
you saying that I am going to get stuck
well a pox on all of you and to those
who don't think I'm going to get stuck
well thank you that's a very pretty
picture Andre so you don't have to be up
to things backside to get a good shot
but we are going to have to move fairly
soon they are going straight back to the
kill road so let's go back there
hello my dear we're going to follow that
lot if you don't mind cause you're just
sitting still good
right while we catch up with the Lions
and they kill using this remarkable
piece of equipment let's go back to
Jamie and the little cheese
speaking of catching up that's exactly
what I've been doing to try and keep up
with Hassan as you can see from the
front of our car and the rest of us then
Craig and myself have been through some
interesting terrain to attempt to follow
him all right a tree will spring right
back up behind us but I'm very careful
about which species of tree we do that -
where's our you just go easy there oh
yes there is
oh he's a bit further ahead than I
thought so he just took us through
something that I would not consider to
be fun he took us through two drainage
lines one of which we very nearly lost
him in he stopped to look at a scrub
here disappeared into some dense
vegetation but that's okay we've managed
it's also not an area where we have much
signal so it's great that he's continued
up onto this Chris
hey boy it's hungry he's really really
hungry I don't think he's gonna stop
moving for the rest of the night until
he catches something I think this is
going to be the story of our evening if
he takes us into Geary cut line well
it'll be like a repeat of James's
evening with Hassan and ting gana she's
aiming for that termite mound I hope
he's aiming for that termite mound
what I'm trying to do is get parallel to
him he's going to go investigate that
furrow all right I'm gonna figure out
exactly where Hasan is going to go and
what he's going to get up to and while
he since the air the sticks I imagine
are thinking about stirring as well
you will not believe what is happening
right 97 I the exact same story that
happened but the Inca homers the stick
sticks pride have decided to or use the
communal toilet and my goodness I have a
scarf over my mouth and Sabres looking
rather green in the face no this has
happened to us twice
we got surrounded by the in comas one
time and we had no choice but to sit
there we've just been hit by a fresh
wave I do apologize it is it's rather
pungent now if I was to describe this I
can't stop looking a safe space I'm not
gonna look at you said I would see this
color is a very orange e brown color
it's very horrible on every level and
I've have heard some people comment that
I think it's possibly Tristan but I
could be wrong say that leopards and
lions scat smell the same I can assure
you in my opinion it does not line scat
there's just nothing like it
I it's very difficult to breathe but I
really really haven't smelled anything
like this before and I personally feel
again my personal opinion is it's worse
than leopards and it is worse than
hyenas oh stick sprayed of course no
this is not uncommon behavior they
regularly all do things together it just
takes one of them to do it and in the
rest of the parade will follow
contagious behavior and this refers to
yawning which is similar in humans I
guess I'll grooming your anything
defecate thing once one gets up slowly
slowly slowly the rest follows suits so
they're starting to get mobile they're
all grooming we're actually not in the
best position should we go forward just
marginally yeah we're just gonna go
forward a slight that's hot just so you
can see the right this was my scarf over
my face but I've removed it now I'll be
brave because most of the Prater over
here
we're just gonna go really really just a
tiny bit forward and you'll be able to
see them and you will see that they're
all Gruman nose so they're a week
they're over they're very sleepy D just
gonna stick my nose in here and stage is
that good step okay and very shortly I
can assure you they will be mobile MGM
thank you so much I really appreciate
that I described it in such a way that
even they can smell it well I'm glad
because Sam and I are suffering here
greatly so I'm just very happy to share
that all with you but of course due to
their diets and all sorts of things that
lines do consume they are skeptics now
the grooming is going on we've got I
think two or three that are flat as
pancakes but very shortly as it starts
to get darker I think I'm gonna have my
work cut out for me and following this
price but it's gonna be very interesting
to see exactly where they go will the
stay and juma or row the exits and
across the boundary so of course we're
gonna stay with them as long as we can
but we're gonna send you guys back up to
the oh la la la la las like another mail
Roger we've now come to the caucus we've
got a good view of the male line and I
will tell you that the rain is starting
to Pelt down that's okay we've got
enough shelter to be able to film them
record to young males one female and the
big male and I'm hoping against hope
that this is where they're going to
remain until half-past eight East Africa
time because if they're don't well it's
going to be a little bit tough when it
comes to our television show
I'm sure you've been here the crunchy
diversity who are a little bit squeamish
I do apologize rest assured this Buffalo
can no longer feel anything
hello look at your new view and you're
wondering if we're in a zoo we can no we
are not in the zoo we are in the Masai
Mara of Kenya and that is not a zoo but
part of a two million acre hectare three
and a half million acre natural
wilderness area here in East Africa and
you're on a live Safari so instead of
having guests on the back of the vehicle
I have the lamentable fellows Andre and
he has got a camera and he is producing
these beautiful pictures and so we're in
a wildlife area and then down south
where you've seen the leopard and the
Lions there in the greater Kruger
National Park a similarly sized
wilderness area and they too are not in
a zoo at all so no these are completely
wild animals and they're not caged
they're totally free to roam and move
around as they feel they'd like to
Oh Ilana I think that lion scat smells
worse than leopard scatter I'm not
saying let the scat smells good by any
stretch but lion scat certainly is one
of the most unpleasant things I've ever
had the misfortune of an inhaling well
not physically the gas coming off - I
mean I shouldn't forget of course and
this is a little bit grim but you know
when you are smelling something you are
in fact taking molecules of that thing
into your nostrils so when you are
smelling something bad like lions get as
small molecules of lions get actually
getting into your nostrils that's a
lovely thought isn't it
that's faith has just saved from the
final control in Johannesburg you
yes very you indeed so you can hear this
rain all the other vehicles have lifted
and I suspected I actually think they
were probably moved out of here by the
park authorities because of so many yet
hmm beautiful asana is on the move
unlike these lines so we're not going to
move at all but Jamie like the chief is
on the move
as well yes so faith could tell James
that is on the move straight to that
spot off Gary cut line where he had that
fun TV show the other well a couple of
weeks ago I'm sure he will be
entertained
he had the flat tire mm-hmm
this could be interesting but we're
gonna do our best we're gonna see if we
can stick with him what I'm going to
warn you all is that we could disappear
almost completely because there's no
signal down here I have to try and stick
with him well before the TV show but
very shortly we are going to vanish off
your screens where is he gone I've lost
him and they didn't get too far ahead
there is oops
hold on Craig let's not put a Tristan
at least if I put a Tristan I can say it
was in the dark yeah
I'm concentrating very very carefully
while I do that and send you across such
Lauren who I think is going to be doing
the same very shortly the stinky sticks
I think we're safe to call them that
stinky sticks that they're absolutely
adorable now we are losing light
dramatically which is of course fiber
and I are so I still can't get a total
count because they're actually
technically should be 10 but we only see
9 of them where which leaves the
question as to where is the missing one
and many of you may be wondering how far
the sticks are from the Inca Houmas so
just to clarify we are obviously in the
sort of southeastern corner of preserve
twin dams very very close to the
southern boundary and Tristan had the
Inca home was way up in the northwest
near Sandy patch so we are both on Juma
but of course there is quite a distance
between the two just in case anyone was
wondering about the locations or being
kuma mother and copies and the sticks
prayed so long ago of course this
territory did belong to the sticks and
'only seems to move off and it's just
amazing that they came back I've heard
so much about this price since I've came
here a lot a lot but of course never
ever thought that I would get the
pleasure to actually see them and here
they are when many of you asked
yesterday this morning and today about
in what would happen within comas and
the sticks if they mate and well
ultimately I think because of the
condition of them the sticks really
don't look too great in terms of the two
halves
well they do have the after-effects of
means in full force look at this look at
the baton going on there for scratching
that's not aggressive at all that's just
one line and helping to sort of scratch
the other and as part of the grooming
process and of course I believe is only
to adult females so in terms of the
strength of each pride who must probably
are slightly stronger in terms of more
older experienced adults and they appear
slightly healthier I guess but you never
know so Lin was asking would our our
Saints ever smell of shampoo or perfumes
I think affect the animals with the
lines be able to smell them well
generally a rule of thumb I hear in the
bush elonis when you're doing your
guiding is not to really put heavy sense
or not would include aftershave and
perfume and strong body sprays and all
the other things females put on because
of course you need to rely on your sense
of smell to know what's going on around
you
I guess the animals because they do have
such strong sense of smell will be able
to smell us we will have an odor a
natural odor I do wash my hair
unfortunately I think it's necessary or
I would end up with probably dreadlocks
by the end of it which wouldn't be too
good so yes we will have an author and
they won't be able to smell it but if
you're asking if it affects us when
effects aim when they know it doesn't
they will just be consciously aware of
it but we don't cover ourselves in
perfume or aftershave or any real strong
smelling scents but of course even when
we wash our hands with hand soap which
is also very necessary out here in the
bush house anywhere in the world
actually a saint comes off that so you
can't really avoid Saints but we
definitely don't overdo it try to avoid
all these smelly strong smelling saints
for yourself as well as the animals out
here I have to say I did think they
would be a little bit more mobile than
this by now but I'm glad they're not I'm
really really glad they're not and both
Sam and I were just discussin I wonder
where they're gonna go my gut is telling
me to look for water and potentially the
neatest sort of water point to here is
tree house them that's the closest one
but whether that is where these sticks
pray choose to go we have a new idea we
have to wait and see
so from the sticks pride in Juma we're
gonna send you all the way up to the Oh
lalala sprayed in Namara yes the Oh
lalala so lovely multicolored gorgeous
scene there of the spinal column the
cervical spinal column and now we moved
to the black rotting flesh on the
ribcage the intercostal muscles still
they're uneven so lots to feed on at the
hola Lola bride killer moment sunset the
rain is coming down that's an
interesting one Stevie yes I suppose it
probably is the rain may well be keeping
the scavengers away in so much as it's
probably stopping the smells getting up
too far from here
but remember that these lions are an
intimidating Bunch and any scavenger
that came past here and saw all of these
lions here would almost certainly just
turn on and go away especially as
there's a big male and so with that may
have been visited by a few scavengers
during the day couple of jackals maybe
maybe I you know came investigating and
then turn on and disappeared also Lions
tend to eat rather quickly and so you
know this kill was not like a migration
kill where they'll sort of snack on half
of it and then leave they'll finish this
Buffalo and they have almost finished
the Buffalo and I don't think it's been
dead long enough necessarily to attract
the scavengers that said when we drove
in it did smell pretty bad so it has
started to rot you know there could be
any number of reasons why there aren't
scavengers here the rain could be one of
them one of the contributing factors
these sounds are the frogs you can hear
the bubbling in Cocina re the Lions will
eat the guts but what they'll need to do
first is clean out the bolus so they'll
take out their actually run the guts
through their teeth and squeeze out the
sort of undigested plant material or
half digestive plant material and then
they will eat the stomach and the
intestines I don't think they have
necessarily a preference they probably
do but I don't know what it is one of
the major limiting nutrients out here is
macro nutrients is fat so they need to
try from an animal like this they need
to try and get as much as fact out of it
as possible and the best way to do that
is to eat things like the viscera all
the guts and then also the organs so the
liver and the kidneys and the heart not
so much the lungs that note suppose it
tends to be a bit of fat around those
organs and after a fairly bounteous time
here in the Mar you can see the grass is
long there's no jardin progress here
you'll probably find that the Buffalo in
pretty good Nick and it was killed and
so there probably is a little bit of fat
there for them to eat I'll enjoy the
brain tooth they can get to it but on
the Buffalo only they will get to it I'm
something like an Impala they cracked
the skull open quite easily
I'd be interested I mean we've only got
we've only seen two lionesses here and
then the two males and I'd be interested
if those the four that took this Buffalo
down I'd be very surprised if the four
of them took this Buffalo down maybe the
male helped them maybe he was here too
then it would have been enough but looks
like a pretty big set big pretty big
bull that they killed it has a very bad
weekend last time I am struck quite
often I suppose especially as I get
older by how we talk about death like
this just as a kind of matter-of-fact
thing when it was of course the ultimate
trauma for that Buffalo to die at the
teeth and claws of these lions nothing I
don't imagine could have been more
terrifying for it we talked about it
fairly glibly I feel sometimes I do
anyway on that note rather sad
philosophical ones it's clear dance I
wonder stack it more cheerful mr. Justin
Dix
well it's no luck flash so far I'm
afraid we are unfortunately Baroness
well what would we call it Baron with
our search for spotted cats
no sign of sobrino sonnet in Ghana and
so we just bumbling now in the hope that
Tandy might show up she's been very
elusive of late doesn't she she's been
very very quiet it's tiny I wonder what
she's been up to you being sneaky time
you two being sneaky she's wrong me up
to something and so maybe she's around
hopefully she'll be around them I think
she's gonna appear for me this evening
because I feel like a 10 deciding it's
been a while since I've seen her
Marcia do they allow research of animals
in the sabi sands yes in some degrees
very unobtrusive Easter so no coloring
or tagging or anything like that but
they will allow like the camera trap
survey that's and there is running now
and liquid density so that's what is
that there in the road is it the scrub
here can you shine down there look down
the road for me just see look scrub
Irish or maybe a little darker so the
way down further down back
yeah what is that I don't think you IR
light will reach myself what is that
it's small whatever it is little gerbil
a bed there's a Nigel well done sir he's
gonna check eyes lit make sure it was
always something gonna be something
small I thought for a second when I
first saw the eyes mouth or maybe chin
it or something like that but I'll ask a
little too small I'm afraid so yes
there's an obtrusive research that's
takes place and there's been a bit of
research on rabies before there's I
think somebody that was researching
recently invasive species of snails
within the sand river which is sounds
delightful
and so yes they do allow some stuff
ground hornbill research is thriving in
the sabi sands a few things but like I
say as unobtrusive as possible for a lot
of the researching so it's trying to
avoid missing with animals as much as
possible and spoke colorings and things
like a tour generally and no no for the
sabi sands and but that doesn't mean we
don't see collared animals so a lot of
you will say but hang on we see colored
animals yes that is true we do we will
see every now and then nod collared
elephants collared buffalo
collards I don't know whatever that
comes across this way and those all
coming out of prega so those are
research animals from Kruger but most of
the Buffalo Nidhi studies are done so
generally when you see that you should
be contacting somebody and saying listen
we've seen this and you know they call
is still on because most the caller's
are next but actually working on some of
those animal difficult to find they when
the collar stops working good I mean to
keep bumbling I mean to hope for a ton
need crediting Garner's any of the T
sightings and while I do that's back
across to Lauren with the stinky sticks
and it's quite beautiful knowing that
you're here underneath the stars as the
night as Senen with the sticks prior
upright you would never ever believe
that you would get to meet and just oh
oh oh oh oh just as predicted there on
the moves are going right into muwah t
you know I think I might move now try
and look round and catch them yeah
because we need to know whether they're
gonna cross or travel done yeah they're
movin right into the mawashi people it
is in fact time to mood I must put my
lights on to make sure yeah one by one
off they go
I knew it so they're either gonna cross
mawashi to the other side or they're
gonna go right down to the southern
border so I just want to try and loop
runs now to find them
sticks and stones is asking do the
sticks have any dominant meals well no
they don't and I don't know which meal
coalition's are honestly affiliated with
this is gonna be a bit bumpy obviously
this is the first time we've seen them
in a long time so I really genuinely
have no idea as they're affiliated with
any Mayo coalition's in the area so it's
all females that we see and I think to
our adults now I don't know how many
we've got right in front of us because
some of them were flat but we did have
nine earlier on so in terms of dominant
males
no there is no males but they can be
associated with coalition's and they
will indeed separate from them and it
all depends when they are meeting
so we're going to try and catch up with
some hopefully we can but for now we're
going to send you guys back up to the
all alors
we have gone into infrared and that is
on account of the fact that the light
has faded to the extent that we are now
unable to use the normal color here
comes the Linus John dree just to the
right hand side approaching at a stately
walk flicking her tail
laughs - he's got a frog in his throat
look what is that the young male just do
me as close as you can get Chandra now
that's a female with a problem account
mangled her poor heart but the poor
condition of her back legs that is a
female isn't it shame she doesn't look
so good
and if she's sick similar to the male
she doesn't seem to have those dots on
her but same kind of poor condition of
the hindquarters one two three four five
very interesting
there's one of the young males very
happy to be eating as all young males
are some even old males quite happy to
be eating I'm one of them yeah a lot of
you saying she walks with a funny gait
sure what do that to her have some
spinal injury it was a circulatory
problem could even be something like a
cancer remember we had a dog once little
Steffi called Cecily and Cecily got
cancer around that area and she looked
quite similar I just can't believe that
that will be the case that would be so
unusual out here but not impossible
and many of you wondering if that
Commission John Drake could you not have
warned me I'm sitting in a comfortable
position everybody I don't even know I'm
wondering if she could be the mother of
the cabs
that's know me a pet the pets all being
killed no I don't think so oh I don't
know it shoots you could be it's
possible I don't think that concurrent
condition is a function of anything to
do with her losing Cubs she may have had
a difficult birth or something perhaps
maybe she gave her at a breech birth or
something like that could have caused
the problem I'd love to hear your
suggestions but that's going to probably
have to be tomorrow I'm afraid we only
have 30 seconds left of this show
remember you can watch our TV show on
YouTube hush-hush nudge nudge wink wink
we'll be on again in half an hour the
innocent of the Lions hopefully the cats
at Duma will play ball if you can't
watch we will see you tomorrow again of
course at 6 o'clock Central African time
we can work out what time that is where
you are in the world until then bye-bye